we are right now joined by the first
finalists it's magnus carlson
congratulations minus
thank you two wins in a row in these two
final games how happy are you with your
chess today
uh you know what uh there are a lot of
things that
i felt like i could have done better
today uh it was certainly better than i
played yesterday but
most of all i will just say that um
i'm in the final i'm very happy about
that um
and i don't take it for granted
especially after what's
happened in in these uh
tournament tournaments over over the
last few months so
i'm just very happy to be uh in in the
final and to have the patch
dispatched of a very strong opponent
fantastic
and magnus the second game we were
following it was a bit of a roller
coaster how did you recover from that
one
uh to win game three uh yeah
that was a bit silly uh since uh
after queen c2 i thought
i regained the bishop and i must be at
the very least
much much better and then i didn't
pause to calculate when i i needed to
uh because i even saw that rookie five
was very strong there
uh i just thought uh
you know what i'll exchange i'll
exchange the queens and i'll win the
ending
pretty easily and then i'd miss this
resource rook b5
uh and then yeah as as you know i i
blundered blended more and was a little
bit lucky to
uh to to um to escape but yeah certainly
roller coaster is uh is up but
at least it told me that he wasn't
that that comfortable and
when it became clear in in the second uh
sorry in in the third game today
that he he also wanted to play i wasn't
i wasn't so unhappy
uh about that because i i thought there
would be very good chances to
to outplay him and that's what happened
so after that final game uh yesterday
magnus did
sort of did you get scared that history
would repeat itself
again and that you would have trouble on
on the second day in the knockout stage
and that
the final would sort of just slip out to
your hands there
uh obviously it could happen
but then again as i said yesterday i was
realistic enough to
uh to understand that i didn't play so
well
yesterday so even though it was annoying
not to have gotten
the match win i i still felt like 2-2
was a decent result and there would be
every chance
today and uh obviously we're
wondering who you're going to face mama
diara or nakamura
they're now going to face each other and
the armageddon so do you
prefer either of them um
no i don't don't prefer any of them but
i think in
in in armageddon nakamura is a pretty
a big favorite so i'm still sort of
assuming that's what's going to happen
but i'll follow it with interest of
course
and we're we're all waiting for the
first tournament win for you magnus
with the way you are playing now does it
feel like this is your tournament to win
now
it could be but i still feel like i have
to up my level
a little bit for for the final all right
finally magnus we did uh have that video
with the memory test
yesterday we have so many reactions on
that and
many people are wondering one thing that
anon
game that david had for you that you
guessed
after only like two moves how are you
able to do that that's what everyone is
wondering
uh so it was a petrov and it's some sort
of notable game
uh anand played
white in the previous game uh
so i just i took a pretty qualified
guess at that point
in general in general
um i would say that most of them
uh i should be able to to get but i'm
proud to have gotten the harry potter
one
that was impressive impressive stuff all
right magnus uh it's going to be
fantastic with the final tomorrow what
will you do now to prepare
uh i don't know to be honest i'll relax
follow
follow the armageddon game and try to
get a good night's sleep
all right well we wish you a good
night's sleep magnus good luck tomorrow
thank you thanks for joining us